last time I saw you you said you were in
discussions that you sat with Eddie
Murphy and you were gonna do a remake up
not a remake but a sequel I guess to
twins where it's gonna be you Danny
DeVito again and now Eddie Murphy they
were gonna find out you have another
brother
I loved this concept I thought this
could be great but I haven't I want to
know where we're at with this and and
we're in a writing stage oh we are so
yeah it's being written our mutual
friend has been dragging his feet a
little bit Ivan Reitman why is he
dragging it's because he wants to
protect the first one and he was worried
that the second one may you know be
better or maybe worse I mean I don't
know I guess it was just that yeah I get
it can be paralyzing can it when you
make a great classic film you say why
should I screw with this
this is absolutely I totally understand
it but we still have to convince him to
go and move faster but we're moving in
the right direction people came up with
some great great stories and I cannot
wait to do it because Eddie Murphy will
be absolutely hilarious
absolutely the third brother did we find
out the Athena how does black guy get
into the leagues and how did this sperm
mixing happen there you notice I think
it's funny yeah